las cicatrices de los seis meses de
ocupación rusa siguen siendo evidentes
en isium Desde que la contraofensivo
ucraniana obligó a las tropas rusas a
retirarse en septiembre muchos intentan
reconstruir sus vidas e identificar a
los muertos
Estoy buscando a mi hermano murió solo
en casa llamamos a la unidad de
exhumación y lo enterraron sin tumba
desde la liberación se han exhumado 750
cadáveres de diferentes fosas
los forenses de este laboratorio móvil
de ADN recién creado y donado por
Francia comparan las muestras de saliva
de las víctimas con el ADN recuperado de
los objetos personales de los
desaparecidos y el ADN que tienen de los
cuerpos no identificados mediante el
análisis genético el laboratorio intenta
evitar a las familias el dolor de la
identificación visual de los cuerpos el
proceso No solo está ayudando a los
familiares sino también a los fiscales
que están construyendo el caso de los
presuntos crímenes de guerra contra
Rusia
estamos llevando a cabo exhumaciones
ahora para proporcionar pruebas legales
de que estas muertes fueron causadas por
la violencia o por objetos explosivos
estamos recogiendo pruebas para La Corte
Penal Internacional
París promete enviar otro laboratorio de
ADN a Ucrania a finales de año se trata
de una buena noticia ya que los expertos
prevén que el proceso de identificación
de cadáveres en el país probablemente
continuará durante años